porte de sortie pour les céréales
bloqués dans les ports ukrainiens la
russie et l'ukraine s'apprête à signer
un accord sur la reprise des
exportations en mer noire suite au
blocus maritime imposé par moscou depuis
le mois de février
nous attendons également pour votre état
des nouvelles en provenance de turquie
concernant le déblocage des ports
d'après les diplomates le texte prévoit
la création de corridors en mer noire
par lesquelles transitaient les bateaux
ukrainien pour ceux qui se rendraient au
port d'odessa il serait soumis à une
inspection d'un pays neutre peut être la
turquie pour vérifier qu'ils ne
contiennent pas d'armes cachées en
échange la russie pourrait à nouveau
exporter plus facilement ces denrées
alimentaires objectif faire baisser les
prix du marché qui ont flambé depuis le
début du conflit et enrayer les risques
de famine qui pèse sur le continent
africain principalement
comme vous le savez nous soulignons de
nombreux - la gravité de la crise
alimentaire dans le monde c'est une
composante grandes composantes de cette
crise si nous pouvons résoudre ce
problème nous pouvons potentiellement
sauver des centaines de milliers voire
des millions de personnes débris
alimentaires hors de leur famille
plus de 20 millions de tonnes de
céréales sont actuellement bloqués dans
les ports ukrainiens